you tell us about the Kickstarter
campaign
what were your ideas going into
launching it what do you think made it
so successful do you felt you did it too
soon too late you thoughts on that well
I don't think that we did the
Kickstarter campaign at the wrong time
obviously you could say if we were
farther along in production then they
would have come out sooner but we needed
the Kickstarter in order to go into
production we needed the Kickstarter
especially to figure out you know the
additional features or changes we were
going to make so in that way it's like
it started whenever it was going to
start and that start was the Kickstarter
campaign in order to actually get the
ball rolling on the project what's kind
of funny is that we spent you know a lot
of time discussing
the rewards and one of the different
levels would be other than the camera
because you know we weren't sure going
in that people would buy all the cameras
because it's a significant investment on
a Kickstarter level most campaigns the
average donation is much much smaller
than an AR campaign and we have one of
the highest average donations of any
Kickstarter campaign I think it was
something like $700 was the average I
think as a reward level that the $2,500
reward level being the highest number of
rewards or more close to it that we have
I think that had not been done before on
Kickstarter there have been a lot of
things that made more money overall but
the actual reward level was very high
yeah I mean I think is it just sort of
funny because you know we spent a lot of
time arguing you know whether t-shirts
should be 40 or 35 but really at the end
of the day what it came down to is
whether people wanted the cameras are
not like the smaller things we
appreciate people's support but we sort
of gained our campaign and that we will
make our goal if we sell out of cameras
and we're only selling 100 so if we
don't sell out then they're sort of
really can't be that much of a market
for the
and so we kind of you know you can never
know going in whether something is gonna
be successful or not in that way we I
don't think we anticipated that it would
go as fast as it did you know we
anticipated having to spend the whole
month actually you know working to get
people's attention and that didn't
happen because you know by the time we
we launched it like a Monday afternoon I
think and then by Tuesday morning when
we came in the original goal was already
met and at the end of that day all the
cameras were sold out so it went very
quickly and I think that that's
something that is unique to our campaign
but doesn't have to be you know we were
creating you know mathematically a model
that would mean if people bought enough
of the product then we would meet the
goal and actually have the ability
to produce that I think one of the
smarter things that we did was capped
the product you know it's it's very
flashy now to get millions of dollars on
Kickstarter but the thing is with you're
trying to raise ten thousand or even a
hundred thousand and you make ten
million your business has changed
significantly
you know there's taxes involved there's
different manufacturing costs involved
as a whole you know how hundreds of
thousands of customers that instead of a
hundred customers that you have to
deliver to you know one of the reasons
we've been able to have personal
relationships with our backers is
because we had a much smaller number of
backers and you know people who were
upset that we didn't add more cameras
but we wanted to make sure that it was a
small group that we would be able to
deliver that
going to become out of control and a lot
of the other tech projects that are out
there have gotten out of control and
that's why they are having problems with
delivering you know because they
anticipated fairly making their goal I
ended up making
[Music]
we're not ready for this
and I think that when you're planning a
Kickstarter campaign you really have to
look through all of these possible
outcomes and you have to understand you
know if I make this much money on
Kickstarter this is what it translates
into business-wise
I you know King started as a great thing
but I think that there's very little
accountability in who can put up a
Kickstarter and what sort of business
strategy or any kind of pre-planning
they've had to do in order to put that
Kickstarter up and I think that some
people just get massively overwhelmed
because they don't know what they're in
for
I donated to a keyboard project on
Kickstarter and the guy really
misunderstood what it was going to take
to make his electronics project or
technology project and he has he made
just barely over his goal and he has now
sold his reverse his investments and but
his all his life savings into the
project on top of that money and it's
still probably not going to be able to
deliver it and I did it's kind of ruined
him financially
it's it's a problem that Kickstarter is
not like a bank they don't ask you for
your business plan they don't ask you
for your market research they don't ask
you for any of that kind of stuff they
leave all that up to you which is which
is a little dangerous for for investing
in and as investors or as backers it's a
little dangerous for backers I think
they also used to be more strict about
the number of the projects that they
would take on at any given
time I you know in this it's hard for me
to tell because Kickstarter they don't
advertise every single campaign on their
site they make it so that you can see
you know recently funded or popular or
staff pics but it's unclear as to how
like what the ratio is between stuff
that you'll see on their homepage and
how many actual keeps their their
campaigns there are but you know when we
first applied for a Kickstarter campaign
was
like November even though we launched it
in March you know we had it approved and
ready to go in November and at that time
you were seeing you know fewer film
projects are fewer simmilar some film
projects so there was they were sort of
curating what projects were acceptable
and which were not and more particularly
on their site itself you didn't have
like 50 music videos at the same time
that they were showing they would show
like one music video one documentary
about this one longer documentary about
this the the projects were not competing
with each other so much and I think
that's part of like a big problem now
too it's sort of the novelty of
Kickstarter has worn off and I think now
you see fewer projects going through
because people are more hip to what it
takes to actually make one of these
products happened
you